can you
try to do the impossible task and give a
whirlwind
introduction to iron rand the
the many sides of iran so i ran the
human being
i ran the novelist and i
ran the philosopher so who was ayn rand
sure so so her life story
is is one that i think is is fascinating
and but it also
lends itself to this integration of all
of these things
she was bonus in petersburg russia in
to kind of a middle class uh family
jewish family
they they owned a pharmacy a father on
the pharmacy
and uh you know she grew up uh
she grew up uh she was a very um
she knew what she wanted to do and what
she wanted to be from a very young age i
think from the age of nine she knew she
wanted to be a writer she wanted to
write stories
that was the thing she wanted to do and
you know she focused her life after that
on this goal of i want to be a novelist
i want to write
and the philosophy was incidental to
that
in a sense at least until some point in
her life
she witnessed the russian revolution
literally it happened outside they lived
in saint peter's book where the first
kind of demonstrations and
and of the revolution happened so she
witnessed it she lived through it
as a teenager um went to school
under the soviets for a while they
they they were under kind of the in on
the black sea
where they opposition government was
ruling and then
they would they would go back and forth
between the commies and the whites
but but she experienced what communism
was like she saw
the pharmacy being taken away from her
family she saw their apartment being
taken away or other
other families being brought into the
apartment they already lived in
um and uh it was very clear
given her nature uh given her views
even at a very young age that she would
not survive the system
so a lot of effort was put into how do
we get how did she get out and her
family
was really helpful in this and she had a
cousin and
cousin in chicago and she had been
studying kind of film
at the university and uh she's in her
20s
this is in her 20s early 20s and
uh lenin there was a small window where
lennon was allowing some
people to leave under circumcis certain
circumstances and she managed to get out
to go do research on film in
in the united states everybody knew
everybody who knew her
knew she would never come back that this
was a one-way ticket and
and she got out she made it to chicago
spent a few weeks in chicago
and then headed to hollywood she wanted
to write scripts that was that was the
that was the uh the goal here's this uh
you know short
woman from russia with a strong accent
learning english showing up in in
hollywood and
you know i want to be a scriptwriter in
english in english
writing in english and and this is
kind of a one of these fairy tale
stories but it's true she shows up
at the cecil b demille studios
and she she has a lot of introduction
from her uh cousin in chicago who owns a
movie theater
and this is in the 19 the late 1920s
and she shows up there with this letter
and they say you know don't call us
we'll call you kind of thing right and
she steps out
and there's this massive um convertible
and in the convertible is cecily demille
and he's driving
slowly past her right at the entrance of
the studio and she stares at him and he
stops the card he says you know why you
staring at me
and she says you know she tells him a
story for russia and you know when i
want to make it in the movies i want to
be a scriptwriter one day and he says
well if you want to
if you want that you know get in the car
she gets in the car and he takes her
to the back lot of his studio where
they're filming the king of kings the
story of jesus
and he says he has a pass for a week
yeah if you want to be
if you want to write for the movies you
better know how movies are made
and she basically spends a week and then
she spends more time there she managed
to get an extension she lines up being
an extra in the movie so you can see
i ran there and i was one of the masses
uh when jesus is walking by and she
meets her future husband
on the sets of uh of the king of kings
she lands up
uh getting married getting her american
citizenship that way
uh and she lands up doing odds and ends
jobs in hollywood living in a tiny
little apartment
um somehow making a living her husband
was an actor
he was you know struggling actors or
difficult times
and in the evenings studying english
writing writing writing writing and
studying and studying and studying and
she she finally makes it
by writing a play that that is
successful
in in in la and ultimately goes to
broadway
um and she writes
her first novel is a novel called we the
living
which is the most autobiographical of
all her novels
it's about a young woman in the soviet
union
it's a powerful story a very moving
story
and probably if not the best one of the
best
portrayals of life under communism and
so you would recommend the book
definitely recommend we the living it's
her first first novel she wrote in the
30s
and it didn't go anywhere because if you
think
about the intelligentsia the the the the
people who mattered the people who wrote
book reviews this is a time
of duante and uh who's the new york
times uh guy in moscow who's
praising stalin to the hills and the
success
so the the novel fails uh but but she's
got a novel out she writes
a small novel let called anthem a lot of
people have read that and it's it's
written in high schools
it's it's kind of dystopian novel and uh
it's won't it doesn't get published in
the us gets published in the uk
uk is very interested in dystopian
novels
animal farm uh and in 1984.
84 was published a couple of years after
i think after anthem
there's reason to believe he read he
read anthem uh
that yeah and uh george orwell rogers
for animal farm yeah just the small side
animal farm is probably top
i mean i would it's weird to say but i
would say it's my favorite book
have you seen this movie out now called
mr jones no
oh you've got to see mr jones what's mr
jones
it's sorry sorry for my ignorance no no
it's a movie
it hasn't got any publicity which is
tragic because it's a really good movie
it's both
brilliantly made it's made by a polish
director but it's in english
it's a it's a true story and jojo wells
animal farm
is featured in it in the sense that
during the story
jojo was writing animal farm and and
he's
the narrator is reading off sections of
any form as the movie is all interesting
yeah and the movie is a true story about
the the first
western journalist to discover and to
write about the famine in ukraine
and so he goes to moscow and then he
gets on the train and he finds himself
in ukraine and it's
it's it's beautifully and horrifically
made so the horror
of the famine is brilliantly conveyed
and then and it's a true story it's a
very moving story very powerful story
and and just very well made movies so
it's it's tragic in my view that not
more people
essentially i was actually recently just
complaining
that there's not enough content on the
the fam in the 30s of you know of stuff
there's so much on hitler like i love
yeah the reading i'm
reading it's so long it's been taking me
forever the the rise and fall is the
third reich
yeah i i love it but i've got the book
to compliment that that you have to read
it's called the ominous parallels it's
leonard pikov
and it's the ominous parallels and it's
about it's about
the causes of the rise of of of hitler
but at philosophical causes so whereas
the rise and fall
is more of a kind of uh the the
existential kind of what happened
um but really delving into the
intellectual
uh intellectual uh currents that led to
the rise of hitler and
maybe highly recommend that and
basically
suggesting how it might rise another
that's the ominous parallel so the
parallel he draws is to the united
states and he says those same
intellectual forces are rising in the
united states and this is
this was published i think in published
in 81
82 it was published in 82 so it's
published a long time ago and yet
you look around us and it's unbelievably
predictive sadly
about the state of the world so i
haven't finished dying man's story i
don't want to i don't know if you want
me to no no
but on that point i'll have to let's
please return to it but let's
now for now let's talk let me also say
just just because
i i don't forget about mr jones it is to
the point you made there are tons of
movies
that are anti-fascist anti-nazi
and that's good but there are way too
few movies that are anti-communist
just almost not yeah and it's very
interesting and if you remind me late
i'll tell you a story about that
but so she publishes anthem and
and then she starts and she's doing okay
in hollywood and and she's doing okay
with
with the play and then she starts on her
on on
the book the fountainhead and she writes
the fontainette and it comes out
um she finishes it in 1945
and she's um she sends it to
publishers and publisher after publisher
after publisher turn it down
and it takes 12 publishers before this
this editor reads it and says
i want to publish this book and he
basically tells his bosses if you don't
publish this book
i'm leaving um
and they don't really believe in the
book so they publish just a few copies
they don't
do a matlab and the book becomes a
bestseller from word of mouth
and they land up having to publish more
and more and more and and it's
you know she's basically gone from this
immigrant
who comes here with very little command
of english uh and and
it to all kinds of odds and his jobs in
hollywood
to you know writing one of the
seminal i think american books she is an
american author
i mean if you read the fountain head
it's not russian
this is not dostoyevsky it feel it feels
like a symbol of what america is in the
20th century
and i mean probably maybe you can
so there's a famous kind of sexual rape
scene
in there is that is that like a lesson
you want to throw in some
controversial stuff to make your
philosophical books work out
i mean is that why why was it so popular
uh do you have a sense
well because i think it illustrated
first of all because i think the
characters are
uh are fantastic it's got a real hero
and i think it the whole book is
basically illustrating this
massive conflict that i think went on in
america then
is going on today and it goes on on a
big scale
politics all the way down to the scale
of the choices you make in your life
and and the the issue is individualism
versus collectivism
should you live for yourself should you
live for your values should you pursue
your passions
uh should you or should you do what your
mother tells you
should you follow your mother's passions
and uh
that's and it's a it's it's very very
much
an individual book about individuals
and people relate to that but it
obviously has this massive implications
to the world outside and at the time
of collectivism just having to be
defeated communism well
not uh fascism and and in in
you know the united
defeated st but where collectivist ideas
are still popular in the form of
socialism and communism
and for the individual this constant
struggle between
what people tell me to do what society
tells me to do what my mother tells me
to do and what i think i should do
i think it's unbelievably appealing
particularly to young people who's
trying to figure out what they want to
do in life trying to figure out what's
important in life
um it it had this enormous appeal it's
romantic
it's bigger than life the characters are
big heroes it's very american in that
sense it's about individualism it's
about the triumph of individualism
and so i i think that's what related and
it had this
big romantic element from the i mean
when i use romantic i use it kind of in
the in the sense of
a movement in art but it also has this
romantic element in the sense of
a relationship between a man and a woman
who's that's very intriguing it's not
only
that there's a uh i would say almost
rape scene right
um i would say but it's also that this
woman is hard to understand i mean i've
i've read it more than once and i still
can't quite
figure out dominique right because she
loves him and she wants to destroy him
and she marries other people
i mean think about that too here she's
writing a book in the 1940s
it's there's lots of sex there's
a woman who marries more than one person
has having sex with more than one person
very unconventional she's having married
she's having sex with rook even though
she's not married to work this is 1945.
and it's um it's very jarring to people
it's very unexpected but it's also a
book of its time it's about individuals
pursuing their passion pursuing their
life and not caring about convention
and and what people think but doing what
they think is right
and uh and and so so i think it's
it's it's uh i encourage everybody to
read it obviously so
that was was that the first time she
articulated
star articulated something that sounded
like a philosophy of individualism
i mean the philosophy is there in we the
living
right because at the end of the day the
the woman
is the the hero we the living is
this individualist stuck in soviet union
so she's struggling with these things
so that the theme is there already it's
not as fleshed out
it's not as articulated philosophically
and it's certainly then
anthem which is a dystopian novel where
the
this dystopia in the future has a has
there's no i everything is we
and it's about one guy who breaks out of
that
i don't want to give it away but but
breaks out of that so
these themes are running and then we
have
and we and they've been published some
of the early unran
stories that she was writing in
preparation for writing her novel
stories she was writing
when she first came to america and you
can see these same philosophical
elements
even in the male female relationships
and the passion
and the you know use in the conflict you
see them even in those early pieces
and she's just developing in the same
philosophically she's
developing her philosophy with her
literature and of course
after the fountain head she starts on
what turns out to be her magnus opus
which is atlas shrugged
which takes her 12 years to publish by
the time of course she brings that out
every publisher in new york wants to
publish it because the fountainhead has
been such a huge success
um they don't quite understand it they
don't know what to do with atlas
shrugged
but they're eager to to get it out there
and indeed it
when it's published it becomes an
instant bestseller and the thing about
the
particularly the fountainhead and alice
shrugged but true of of even anthem and
we the living
she is one of the only dead authors
that sell more after they've died than
when it was your life now
you know that's true maybe music we
listen to more beethoven than when he
was alive but it's not true typically of
novelists
and yet here we are uh you know
uh was it 50 you know 60 years
after the 63 years after the publication
of shrugged
and it sells probably more today than it
sold when it was a bestseller when it
first came out
you